elden ring has a new mod for those
looking for an extreme challenge and
overwatch 2 is breaking up with loot
boxes
what if every enemy in elden ring was
millennia that's something youtuber
bushy must have asked before using the
fifth man's enemy randomizer mod to turn
every boss normal enemy and even
wildlife into the game's toughest boss
bushy documented the whole experience on
youtube and somehow still managed to
beat the game in around 8 hours despite
the constant appearance of millennia at
times bushy faced three to five of them
at a time yet still persevered i'll
leave a link to the full video down
below if you want to check it out as
well as a link to the mod if you want to
punish yourself but before you run off
and install that mod let's talk about
overwatch 2 because today blizzard
revealed more details about the game in
its own dedicated event as previously
announced the pvp component of overwatch
2 releases on october 4th 2022 has a
free-to-play game this will kick off
season 1 which will feature all of the
previously confirmed content the switch
to 5v5 new character sojourn and junker
queen the addition of a seasonal battle
pass is a major turning point for
overwatch as this will coincide with
blizzard ditching loot boxes despite
being the way in which cosmetics and
rewards have been distributed throughout
the life of overwatch the new game does
away with them completely in favor of
both battle passes and a store from
which you can buy content directly
overwatch 2 will get a new season every
9 weeks with its own battle pass with
every other season introducing a new
character which translates into one
every four to five months the seasons
that don't add a new character will
instead get other types of content like
maps and game modes this also signals a
major change for the future of overwatch
given that the irregular cadence of
major content updates has long been a
sticking point for the community season
2 will launch on december 6th and
include a tank hero map and more skins
in 2023 we'll get the long awaited pve
mode details of which remain scarce in
other fps news activision has revealed
the road map for what players can expect
from call of duty season 4 mercenaries
of fortune which arrives on june 22nd
for starters season 4 will introduce a
new set of operators to vanguard and war
zone with special operations task force
immortal and as always season 4's battle
pass will include 100 tiers of new
content with two new dlc weapons in the
free tiers for war zone there will be a
brand new fortunes keep resurgence map
this new map will also add new contracts
like the black market run and cash
extraction to the game for vanguard's
multiplayer season 4 is adding two new
maps one is a reimagining of the uss
texas map from call of duty world war ii
the second which will arrive later in
the season is desolation a small to
medium-sized map set in a dense village
littered with destruction the
mercenaries of fortune update will go
live for both vanguard and war zone
following a june 21st update in vanguard
at 9 a.m pacific 12 p.m eastern and a
war zone update at the same times the
next day let me know what you think of
the overwatch 2 changes in the comments
below and i'll see you tomorrow
you